hey flash fans I'm Liana Galera and
right now I'm joined by the coolest girl
I know actress and director danielle
Panabaker hey Annie hi so good to see
you nice to be here so excited because
this is your second time directing the
flash so first of all congratulations
yeah now this is a very kind of James
Bond inspired
yeah the sowed when you found out that
this was gonna be your episode what was
your initial reaction I was really
excited they gave me a little bit of a
heads up you know just in terms of
preparation and it was great every time
I get on an airplane I'd watch a
different James Bond movie and I've not
seen a lot of them to like so go way
back and see some of the Roger Moore
ones and Sean Connery
I mean they've evolved a lot over the
last 50 years for sure and I've actually
already seen the episode it's very
stunts heavy it is it's fantastic you
guys had some of the biggest stunts I've
ever seen you do on the show is that a
big challenge for you it was a new
challenge the first episode I directed
had a lot of visual effects and special
effects and this episode you're right
had a ton of stuns but our son's team is
incredible they've been on the show I
think since season one and we you know
read the script we were talking about
some ideas and what if we tried this and
I was like if you can pull that off go
for it and they did and they did a
really fun job well every time you step
behind the camera it's always so fun and
the fans get so excited so in
celebration of you being here I pulled a
couple fan questions from Twitter
awesome our first one is coming to us
from at Daley D Panabaker
and they said how was the experience of
directing again and how was the
experience different from the first time
it was definitely different I felt more
confident this time for sure I think the
first time I was very concerned with you
know being on time and being on budget
and doing everything very you know
efficiently and this time I slowed down
a little bit more and we got to relax
and try a few things which was great
mm-hmm we have another really fun fan
question about you right now
and you know that I told you that I have
a little bit of surprise yeah so this is
actually going to be a special fan video
message and let's go ahead and enroll
that for Danny oh let's see fan
questions for danielle Panabaker what's
your favorite part of directing the
flash what's your least favorite writing
who are your favorite actors to work
with which actors you'd rather have
replace with the tennis ball on a stick
oh here's one now when Tom Cavanaugh
directs he prefers to be in the scene
that way he can tell the quote stupid
actor where to go and what to do that
guy sounds like an idiot how about you
danielle panabaker do you prefer to be
in the scene you're directing or not
being the scenery also bonus question
why are you so awesome I love that
that's the best kind of fan right yeah
yeah exactly someone who's like
literally been in the trenches with you
and seen you in your worst moments like
that's you know I feel that way about
Tom and I I just adore him that was
really great do you prefer to be in the
scene I actually prefer not to be in the
scene and Tom is unbelievable and so
talented and I've watched him do it you
know he can when he's in a scene with
actors he's so gifted and so talented he
can really take the scene in a different
direction in a surprising direction
especially when he's directing however
when I'm directing I just want to be
directing to be in the scene and you
know trying to watch for everything else
is still a bit of a challenge for me
it was particularly hard there's a
sequence in tonight's episode where
Cecile and killer frost are sort of
cyrano de bergerac and Chester and we
actually shot those scenes at the same
time which is not something you
typically do and it was very challenging
to be directing a scene that I'm in and
also to be directing a scene I'm not
even watching I'm just listening to on
an earwig so it was cool it was fun but
it's absolutely one of the bigger
challenges for me definitely so not only
do we have big news because you're
directing yet another episode of flash
but also Danny congratulations thank you
you are pregnant yeah
you and Hayes are expecting your first
child together how are you feeling right
now
good I'm feeling good right now I was
really nauseous at first
but feeling much better yeah yes now
what can you tease about your pregnancy
journey right now what can you share
with the fans I'm in my second trimester
and it's been great you know feeling
really good right now trying to enjoy it
because I have a feeling it's not always
gonna be this way yeah well the fans are
so excited for you we have another fan
question right now and this is coming
from at Kirin Goodfellow and she says is
Kaitlyn going to have a baby or are they
going to hide your belly congratulations
by the way
thank you I don't think Kaitlyn's going
to have a baby I think the intention is
sort of to ignore my rapidly growing
size so we're playing a fun game of hide
the bump laughs done before yes I have
complete faith that it will be done
again so hopefully it won't be too
obvious did that ever cross your mind of
having Kaitlyn get pregnant I mean it's
not up to me it's up to the writers I
you know I told them when I when I was
pregnant and sort of left it up to them
to make a plan however they wanted to
and I think they have a great vision for
the rest of the season
hmm yeah well it's funny because you and
I were talking about the fact that
you've been playing killer frost a lot
more than season instead of Kaitlyn so
it would have been very interesting if
all the sudden Frost was with child I
know she's the boyfriend I know it is
nice though the killer Frost's clothes
are a little bit looser than Kaitlyn's
were that's for sure yeah well speaking
of though let's take a look at killer
frost she's got her killer new costume
this year are you still loving to wear
that one yes I love that suit I think
it's great you know it feels very
powerful it's designed in such a cool
way you know there's all sorts of like
laser-cut into it that catches the light
it feels badass yeah well the fans are
loving it right now but they also have a
couple more questions for killer frost
okay this fan question is coming from at
best of Kate snow and they're saying
last season we saw that Kaitlyn's mom
became a metahuman is she coming back
this season and will she become a
villain like icicle I'm a huge fan of
Susan's who plays my mom and I think and
I hope we'll see her again imagine
that's not the last you've seen her what
else do you want to see from killer
frost this season because we've gotten
to see her really take the reins yeah
live a little
it's been fun you know one of my
favorite things
they've done the season and I hope we
still get to do more of it she's making
a lot of mistakes like she doesn't
handle things well and she's very sort
of adolescent in that way and that's
been fun to sort of play this obnoxious
teenager who reacts badly and hopefully
learns her lesson
well it's just fun because Caitlin's
always been very in control yes she
knows when something isn't appropriate
to say so to see Frost just kind of go
off and say anything that she's thinking
it's been really fun with that I'm like
for you as an actress it's been great
you know it's very fun to get to make
different choices and to make different
choices than Caitlin would make and to
you know swing for the comedy sometimes
sometimes it's a swing and a Miss but
hopefully hopefully it goes well
I'm gonna pivot to something that I'm
actually really excited to talk to you
about right now okay and that's the fact
that one of my favorite of your past
projects stuck in the suburbs is now
available second life on Disney plans
yes fans can watch this Disney Channel
original movie now now I'm curious to
know have you been in contact with
Brenda's song and hearing Killen like
have you talked to them I have seen both
of them over the years it's funny Brenda
and I were just emailing and I I think
it's pretty incredible I love it I love
that fans are finding it I think Taryn
just changed his like Twitter profile
photo to one of these which is amazing I
love that people are so excited to have
it back I love seeing on Twitter when
people are watching it again it's great
I we had such a fun time making up that
movie you know we were 16 it was awesome
so it's nice I love those having what do
you remember most about filming it just
having fun with Brenda we really had a
good time you know bike riding which I
don't think I was particularly good at
teryn had like extensions in for half of
the shoot and not for the other half
it's funny the director I actually just
saw the director of that movie on an
airplane I hadn't seen him Savage T
fallin in a long time
and I ran into him on an airplane
because that's where I spend most of my
time I'm either at work or on a plane
and you said that you've been in contact
with Brenda as well she's gonna show
Dollface coming out looks awesome
fantastic oh I haven't seen it yet
that's great it's so amazing would you
guys ever want to collaborate again on a
future project Oh a hundred percent I'd
work with her again in a heartbeat on
anything I'll go over on doll face
anytime just call we need we need to
make this happen we need to make
those happen circling back to flash we
have another fan question that I think
that you're gonna like this is from at
Pepe Park and they said could you
describe crisis on Infinite Earths in
one word now I think you're gonna like
this cuz you can't even say anything
about it so I'm sure you can give me one
word whoa
that would be the word were you able to
read all the scripts yes I read all of I
read all the first drafts then things
get a little busy I'm not in as many of
the episodes this year as I've have
historically which has kind of been nice
for me have a little bit of a break yeah
but I am I'm in two of the episodes and
I did read them all okay what was your
reaction when you read them they're
great I feel like you know six years
this is our sixth time doing it which is
crazy I still remember when we did our
first crossover and it was just you know
a couple people coming to flash and a
couple people going to arrow and now
it's become I mean it's a month long
it's a production you know what I mean
it feels like its own separate entity
and it's pretty incredible to see how
far they've come
and now the shows hopefully the show's
maintain their own sense and you know
it's the same tone hopefully a flash
episode still feels like a flash episode
but just with some friends oh I love
that I love that we'll get some burgers
yeah exactly bring big belly burgers or
it's they always make them look so good
they really do yeah I usually just eat
the fries well I'm just so excited that
you are back directing again and we
actually have a fun fan question right
now that we're gonna wrap things up with
this is from at Alice Kane's and she
says if you could direct any other DC TV
show on the network which one would it
be
I think the next one I'd really like to
direct a Supergirl I feel like tonally
they're pretty similar to flash it's
still got a lightness to it and
obviously I love Melissa and that cast
so and they also tend to be a more
visual effects heavy episode versus like
arrow that was a very stubbed heavy
episode or stunt heavy show so that's my
dream yeah what are the chances we can
make that dream into a reality I
wouldn't love to it's hard because we
basically shoot at the same time now I
would have to leave flash for a couple
of episodes to go direct
for girl so I don't know can team flash
survive
I mean honestly at this point like
everything is going wrong so I don't
know it doesn't look great but there
also are so many new faces in STAR Labs
that I'm like I think you could get away
with it it's true yeah but I do love the
fact that since you were the first
female from our arrowverse to direct an
episode you've really sparked a whole
new wave of female directors Katie
Cassidy Katie law it's really stepping
behind I think melissa is doing an
episode as well what does that mean for
you I mean it's incredible I think it's
so important that women support other
women and I've done my best to I mean
look all of these women are very
talented and very capable and I know I
know both Katie and Katie killed it and
I'm sure Melissa's gonna do great but
it's been you know I think it's
important if there's a really nice
community of those women and we share a
lot together and I'm really proud of
them and excited to see what they'll do
next
amazing
[Music]